nous sommes en direct avec nicolas vidal
directeur de la publication de putsch
médias nicolas vidal bonjour merci des
murs direct sur rt france alors ce 14
juillet le premier depuis 1979 célébrer
sans défilé militaire sur les champs
elysées beaucoup regrettent l absence de
la traditionnelle parade militaire est
ce que vous partagez cet avis il ya une
crise du coronavirus bien entendu qui a
fait un format réduit
c'est c'est un peu le but aussi de cette
manifestation via cette célébration en
dirons nous du 14 juillet sept hautement
symbolique pour les français parce que
c'est aussi la concorde on le rappellera
que la prise de la bastille 14 juillet
mais aussi c'est la fête des fédérations
appelé par le commandant lafayette donc
duc de 799 de 4,90 pardon donc c'est
aussi cette fête n'a cette célébration
c'est la france qui se retrouve c'est la
france qui comme lui donc pour moi
aujourd'hui je vais être un peu taquin
mais cette scène elle un goût finalement
cette célébration du 14 juillet pour
menu mac rendu schizophrénie finalement
historique parce qu emmanuel macron le
sait avec la politique qu'il a menée
aujourd'hui sur sur l'ensemble de la
france depuis deux ans c'est assez c'est
assez étonnant
voilà dans le symbole donc le ses
symboles autre symbole le symbole de la
nation retrouver la concorde eux
regardent ça sur la place de la concorde
c'est ton nez et finalement aussi une
politique de wengen bacon qui ne croient
pas beaucoup en la france et on pourra
en reparler
alors le président qui va également s
exprimer après cette cérémonie à la
télévision alors on le sait il avait
déjà renoncé à ses traditionnelles
allocutions présidentielles du 14
juillet finalement aujourd'hui il va se
prêter au jeu
comment peut-il rassurer les français
sur sa capacité à diriger le pays à le
sortir de la crise alors que sa cote de
popularité
alors premières informations ce matin
j'ai fait ma revue pressé j'ai lu chez
les confrères du figaro chez nos
confrères du figaro qui est manuel bas
coûts avait failli annuler cette femme
est entretien vendredi après-midi dans
la précipitation finalement il a même
tenu donc emmanuel macron on imagine que
l'entretien avec m disruptif et vous
savez ce mot à la mode dans l'équipe de
communication du manuel macro ni
subversif
qu'est ce qui va faire emmanuel macron
il va continuer à dérouler son projet
parce qu emmanuel macron la différence
du général de gaulle on rappellera qu'un
hommage au général de gaulle sur ce
défilé du 14 juillet et c'est bien
normal
une manuelle macro hiver ce projet donc
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va nous
remettre sur la table la réforme des
retraites la réforme d'assurance chômage
donc cet entretien mais finalement vous
savez il a parlé 600 jours en conseil
ministre emmanuel macron moi je crois
que ça va être finalement l'affirmation
des 600 prochains jours de galère pour
les français donc je crois qu'il va
continuer et il va continuer à dérouler
son programme face dans cet entretien la
chose qu'il avait abandonné en 2017 et
qui revient au goût du jour mais une
petite précision tout de même la seule
chose que je vois là c'est qu'emmanuel
maccoyii est assez fébrile sur le temps
de la communication voilà il ya un
projet gelé toujours dit sur vos
antennes mais même le projet très claire
c'est oui va que ça plaise ou non c'est
comme ça il sait où il va mais par
contre en terme de communication ce
moment je le sais un peu fébrile
emmanuel macron et cette annulation
cette non annulation de dernière minute
montre quand même laisse apparaître une
certaine fébrilité dans la communication
sait comment jouer par l'offensive
qu'est ce que je vais leur dire mais
finalement je vais leur dire la même
chose qu'il ya depuis deux ans où elle a
pas mais les hommages qui sont rendus ce
matin lors de cette cérémonie du 14
juillet on l'a dit à l'est le personnel
hospitalier qui étaient en première
ligne mais surtout le général de gaulle
la figure historique du général de
gaulle revendiquons un petit peu cet
héritage justement de molester emmanuel
macron veut redorer son blason et ce
qu'elle cherche à se donner une stature
d'homme
tha non pour moi c'est la schizophrénie
air sol eu quand on va signer l'odieux
traiter des clashs appel il ya deux ans
avec un gay l'américain on peut pas se
réclamer du gaullisme et encore moins de
ski et la souveraineté de la france
moi je pense qu emmanuel macron c'est un
hommage qui peut il peut pas il peut pas
ne pas le faire cet hommage au général
de gaulle à la croix de lorraine
mais il a tellement abîmée l'amd france
emmanuel macron que je le redis une
nouvelle fois pour moi c'est à ce goût
absolu de schizophrénie historique donc
oui john le bol on ne peut pas entendre
pour les souverainistes et les amoureux
de la france les français sur la nation
et du territoire de l'enracinement de
gaulle est un visionnaire de gaulle et
l'homme d'état de gaulle est l'homme de
la vision pour la france de la grandeur
de la france donc emmanuel macron il
correspond pas du tout il ne coche
aucune case du gaullisme ce même mois
pour moi j'avais dit sur l'antenne c'est
l'anti de gaulle emmanuel alors le chef
de l'état qui l'a prendre la parole pour
la première fois depuis le remaniement
ministériel
nous sommes à deux ans de la
présidentielle
est-ce que les déjà en campagne
elle m'apprend celle en cours alors il
est en campagne sur wii peut-être
effectivement mais c'est surtout qui fut
je le redis tout en un c'est qu'il a un
projet manuel mâcon et qui doit
absolument aller d'ici 2000 2022 il
mettre ces réformes centrale la réforme
des retraites si sa réforme mer dont
emmanuel macron il a continué à pilonner
avec cette réforme des retraites alors
qu'ils se réveillent il va peut être se
représente pour moi finalement ce projet
là s'il estime que ce projet là n'est
pas terminée à la fin de son mandat il
se représentera emmanuel macron parce
que j'ai toujours vu finalement comme
directeur général des services de
l'union européenne de bruxelles pour
lequel il ya une feuille de route qui
veut mettre en place si la réforme des
retraites c'est vraiment son son kata
emmanuel macron est alors oui il va pas
ils peuvent composer il se présente est
peut-être en 2022
mais concrètement ça ne sera toujours
sous l'homme de ce projet néolibéral qui
met en place et avec cet hommage de
soignants c'est quand même bien
dérisoire parce que le symbolisme ne
doit pas être l'avis de leur mandants et
du mépris pour le personnel soignant
justement dans ce conteste dans ce
contexte est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à
une rentrée sociale en septembre
explosive oui je vais vous dire oui
effectivement même d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui je crois que les soignants
manifeste bastille et 14h des liaisons
sont prêts le l'igpn en ce moment donc
nous devons comprendre bien que déjà le
ferment explosif sociale est déjà là on
le dit à chaque fois la crise économique
d'être redoutablement terme de
licenciement en termes de jeunes qui
vont arriver vite cent mille jeunes qui
vont arriver sur le marché non plein et
puis une nouvelle fois ses réformes
imaginer où la réforme la réforme
d'assurance chômage pardon avec un
nombre de chômeurs considérable pour
septembre octobre
on est dans une folie absolue donc
forcément ça va générer des tensions
sociales des manifestations et personne
ne peut dire aujourd'hui qu'elle éveille
d'intensité et surtout si emmanuel
macron continue sa feuille de route bien
marquer avec son stylo rouge
oui c'est sûr et certain que la cie
change pas de cap ne sera pas de karpin
soyons très clairs oui c'est on va
s'affronter il va s'affronter manuel da
cruz à une des tensions sociales
redoutable qui va être agrégées par ce
que j'appelle depuis un certain temps
l'agrégat des colères finalement cette
agri vers des colères qui va donc vite
rejoint par une série de gens sont au
chômage sur la précarité la
paupérisation
et oui mais lumineux mais penche
changera pas de cap pas une seule
seconde
merci beaucoup nicolas vidal d'avoir
réagi sur notre antenne je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de la publication de
pucci mise